who is the forward the cornerstone of
the forward party like in the electorate
who's out there that's like yo yang gang
forward party this is us yeah so the the
forward party early adopters have been
people who are fed up with the two-party
system and those people
tend to overlap very heavily with
business owners entrepreneurs operators
tech people i was just at the bitcoin
conference so those guys so folks who
are into bitcoin libertarians are
definitely in there too um and so i i
joke that it's like a tribe of the
people that uh
are concerned about excessive tribalism
you know what i mean and that that tribe
of people tends to be
these like rational pragmatic business
types
this is you though everything he's
describing business owners operators
free thinkers
you know libertarian almost
what's your hesitancy to maybe being
like yo
yang gang it up forward party like what
what's the flaws and what's going on we
haven't even gotten into that yet i mean
that's a whole different conversation to
have no for me
uh uh
here's where i would go with this all i
think of everything with me is
sequencing you know you've been around
me long enough to know what sequencing
is so
if his goal is to make forward party a
real household name okay hey i left the
democratic party to start the forward
party here's who i am and i left cnn
october 2021 and i'm doing a forward
party okay
you have to have a who was on bill maher
five days ago so you have to have the
platform to get the eyeballs for the
right people to keep seeing it right
that's why and he's got it he's being
picked up but i wonder if this is
president
this is where he's at today
is there four steps before getting here
and it's the mistake if he goes
automatically to here so
we may you know like somebody may say no
he can't do that well why can't he do
that well trump did it but trump already
had a massive audience you know
apprentice business success well he's an
entrepreneur not at trump's level well
he was on tv not necessarily before he
ran for office because he didn't have an
apprentice so that's the part where what
needs to happen in between because if
you don't
you know india's got 45 political
parties how many of them do we know 45
50 political parties so you and i can go
start a political party tomorrow but to
really make a third party like him that
he's talking about really excel george
jorgensen is going to be here tomorrow
why is she here tomorrow because joe
jordan was like hey this libertarian
concert makes a lot of sense how come it
hasn't taken off and that libertarian
90 of crypto is all libertarian that's
who they are they see themselves as
libertarian how come there's not been a
candidate that's blown up on the
libertarian side you got john mcafee
okay who else do we have john
jorgensen and all this stuff but how
come no one's taken off
there i think there is some steps in
between
to your point patrick uh
if you look at the democratic and
republican party they have this giant
media infrastructure behind them so if
you wanted a third-party movement you'd
probably need a parallel uh
infrastructure they have a donor network
you would need one of those they have
various uh influencers parroting talking
points which you don't necessarily want
people parroting but
so so that there's like this massive
infrastructure that needs to get built
um
and uh in my view and i actually have
this experience every single day because
of what i'm doing there are more and
more americans who are like okay i get
it like we need to build uh this
parallel uh party infrastructure you
know uh let me roll my sleeves and and
get to it and some of those people are
you know like folks who were republicans
or democrats or just like that this is
not gonna work as it is if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]